[Music]
in January six men allegedly raped and
murdered a Muslim shepherd girl in
India's Kashmir province their motive to
terrorize the girls community the
accused are Hindus at first the crime
went unnoticed
then marchers under the banner of the
so-called Hindu unity platform began
protesting arrests in the case
two state ministers from India's ruling
BJP as well as local leaders from the
opposition Congress party attacked the
marchers that's when it became a
national story outraged Bollywood stars
demanded justice on Twitter the
crowdfunding effort for the child's
family quickly exceeded its target
outrage forced national politicians to
react Congress party president Rahul
Gandhi led a midnight protest in Delhi
Prime Minister Narendra Modi declared
that our daughters will definitely get
justice yet the small minority of Hindu
extremists has attacked those
campaigning for justice accusing them of
defaming Hinduism the RealD Famers of
Hinduism are those who march in support
of alleged murderers under the banner of
the faith and those who minimize the
crime the Hindus who stand up for the
murdered child may not wear their faith
on their sleeves but they represent its
best face how do you think people should
best represent their faith let us know
in your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI